yes so let's let's see what we what
we're doing we had label cover you know
our favorite thing we had set some
labels here to the left and right you
know we had the small set here at lunch
sit here and the way we want to do this
here if we want to code this by tables
which should be long coats so you know
correct proves we have F of U of X with
X labeling and we had sort of excellent
completeness and soundness here and the
point is that the thing we want to if
you're studying predicate p we really
want that if you look at any I if you
look at why I Zi and and you know x at
the corresponding projected points this
should be true that's sort of how to get
results for the constraints as
fracturing during the predictor p and
one thing that we've assumed so far is
that general disrespect negations which
is called folding and that's what i will
introduce negations in the constraint
satisfaction problem when you look at
the spurious the unscrupulous proved
irby cuz he whatever he puts in these
tables will be negated when you want
that number or that's it and then we
were ingested imperative to the main
thing we analyzed would write it in the
symmetric form that the product of these
three things was one with high
probability and minus 1 others and then
we just did some young basically
manipulations of free coefficients to
prove the deflects scepters was more
than 1 plus gamma over 2 then in fact
gamma squared was smaller than this
expected value and here we use the
notation pi 2 and pi 2 or yes to things
with an old number of pre images on the
under part and then we compare this to
the probabilistic labeling and the
probabilistic labeling is just that you
pick a random fate
the corresponding probability of the
Fourier coefficient and then a random
element and this symmetrically for for
the other for the labeling on the other
side any questions comments last time
you're all happy with this there was
homework there was homework from last
time yes yes I was really soon good did
you do the homework I was preparing to
the lecture I have an excuse yeah so
okay so let them before we we I'll go to
come to the homework we shouldn't worry
yeah so one thing we changed is when
we're interested in max reset we should
do the or of this well sorry we this the
task of course is standing in the end to
check that f of X G of wine G of Z is
this one whatever property you have
normal the property but we said let's
take this protocol that was initially
done for parity maybe change these two
guys and then in fact we have the
property that for any three bits the war
was almost certainly true when we got
the result for parity and to do this we
in fact you know proved you know that
expectation of F was small the
expectation of you know the the g's were
small and the pairwise expectations for
school okay so I want to make you
so if you look at these
so you want to make an observation if
you look at these three bits in the
completeness case we in fact have the
penalty of these three pizzas almost
always one but in the soundless case we
prove that the parrot is equally often
wonder serum but then we also looked at
what other these expectation and I claim
impacted implies if you look at these
three bits it's hard to find an
assignment will get anything except the
uniform distribution it's not only that
you're the predicate perica d string
with the predicate three set of these
three bits takes the expected value in
fact all eight possibilities for these
three bits appear equally often and that
follows because we are once the
expectations of what these three all you
know products is small that means we
have essentially the uniform
distribution because that's you're happy
with this one adding these mines well
yeah if you have but whatever whatever
is that it was yeah parrot it was minus
1 i'm gonna throw not let you see okay
what would you wait to the last name is
more to my well no I shouldn't worry i
also have some chocolates and goods and
this turns out first by slightly
different definition this is actually a
tie koala parrot is useless
you
we'll just desperate but I don't really
want to answer the other definition of
useless but this is equivalent with the
definition of useless i have great m
so now we get to the homework situation
what did bad
you
you
you
this is the protocol grab step s43 sat
you
if you get a product over the Exiles and
for each of them you can win how
probability minus one
alright let's call this jay rather
this is what you get right you did work
a little bit version for you prefer an
apple right so now you're Testament it I
mean this is a lot more fun if you try
to estimate this right so now you can do
it online and we'll go slower so you
really want this term to be small right
i mean it is you're in a very bad
situation if this is about big term
because this is going to kill you right
you want this to be arbitrarily small
when delta goes to serve
okay I mean
you
you
so yeah so you're sort of its you
bounded away from one at least by a
pretty good morning okay and the other
one is well each of these guys you know
it everything that appears you can never
get expectation with an absolute value
that's one but you get sort of something
that's a little bit and in fact each guy
is you know if you take the absolute
value of this it's 1 minus cos / to do
by the size of the projection okay so in
fact but then we have an area any oldest
jets can they all be even for instance
excuse me I ain't observation tools for
every even and odd yeah and claim it's
always true huh right because you're
taking the average of two numbers one is
absolute value one and the other one is
absolute right let's drink to smaller
than one for you right so the the worst
terms are actually SJ equipped with two
because then this is one and this is
almost 11 s j equal to one is pretty
good there then its biggest desktop all
right
we get something like
1-2 some of the square there's a we good
idea don't get whatever something like
right so let's work now okay guys if you
didn't do the homework will have to do
it in class do we have any old desk days
to start with today won't be even know
they stay some of the cardinalities
better write this so yes they can be
even but in that case G hat is 0 yes
because we have an odd function so in
fact you know we have an odd size beta
so at least we have one more guy which
is good you won't choke it so that's
pretty good and so
y
you
okay and that
that this is minus one and that's sort
of almost won because SJ is smaller than
the size of beta and in fact you get a
term which is Colonel to operate at
lunch time okay so these are easy to
control this which would be good to see
what what why you think you're better
because it's the moxie I mean SJ a
smaller than beta right so this this
which means that this number is roughly
1 minus 2 Delta SJ o it is roughly 1
minus 2 Delta modulator ok ok and then
you cancel this 1-1 from here this goes
away and then you have the depth of it
ok
Oh
what so much if the projection is large
is this good you know so if the
projection is much larger than the one
over Delta then in fact you know learner
this one will help us but down here on
Samos is the difference between the
protection of beta and beta so now there
are two ways around it okay and I like
the first way which nobody ever read so
I'm going to tell you this this how I
did I couldn't sketch how i did it in my
original paper and then I gonna tell you
how to do it easily okay because I liked
the way it with my original paper and
it's a useful trick because it's been
used once more okay
when we are sorry i erase this we have
squared x + y de Matos juice
oh my
and maybe before can you I miss together
with why when beta is small great one
contribution form in all this J well
paid I saw both sides right so which
means that since this SJ is some of the
cardinality of beta one of them has to
be old and an old small numbers good for
us what kids yes I break down for
Bracken's like this this this is
you
you
fixed well let's take a fixed point
clearance or be happy just to do the
expectation we pick a random neighbor
okay so we pick the expectation of a
random neighbor and the point is that
you can prove that if the size of beta
is large then in fact the projection
won't be that small on average in fact
to control some power of the size of
Raiders yeah for the historical able
cover that we had I mean the very the
very starting label cover that you know
I sort of constructed it's not absolute
I don't know if this is abstractly true
in a label cover but it was true in the
one I had okay so can you say that again
why is why is it better than one ever
seen a type of them well so soon how
does this thing work well you have 3k
variables here and you're sort of
randomly pick a variables of them and
then you can sort of see if you take a
set here with lots of assignments they
can't all go inside to the same one it's
sort of a means not immediately easy to
see this but you can produce if you work
for one okay
so it's not toy in general for labor
colors now it's probably not true in
general you can look at the label year
the world every all the projections
always project to just one value that
yeah there's not true abstractly but it
was true for this before yeah probably
for how they become a new expects its
probability probability where the truth
of the enemy yeah you're fixed you fix
the be here and you look at the
probability or around them you and then
that this would be then for all better
all are better for all our faith are the
probability for this particular beta
that if we project onto something
extremely small is very unlikely okay
ok so this sort of sets that extremely
large that are fine you know if because
that because it will be taken care of by
this condition and the small sets are
also fine because of observation to from
no observation one right right sure so
some time you look at these guys they
don't match you know there's some some
range of you so they sort of an interval
there's an interval depending on Delta
of bad sizes so how you solve this
Oh
so what's the way to solve this well
this sort of says that we have an
interval of bad size which depends on
Delta so we'll just have a large number
of Delta eyes which has these bad
intervals disjoint okay so we'll start
with the first Elton and now we will
make sure and then we pick a much
smaller Delta so that the small so all
that problematic things are actually
Smalling with regards to this new
husband and then you just pick your
random Delta and then you're fine that's
how I sold it in there yeah so you pick
one day 9 you construct the whole
instance with the single but you first
you start with the starting data and
then you and make this Delta 0 okay and
then you make sure that Delta and then
you'll let's look at the sizes of betas
so we really wanted to run the original
thing with them is certain Delta's we
put delta 0 equal to delta and we sort
of on the sizes on on the sizes of betas
this sort of a schematic finger on the
sizes of beta will have the part of the
for you master because this won't hurt
us because of the first condition that
part of the four ms encodes there won't
hurt us for the second condition and
then we just make sure that we pick a
delta 1 such that i got the one sort of
fools out here and i will sort of have I
Delta K here oh k minus 1 that will
disjoint and the test will now is to
pick a random I ok and use Delta equal
to Delta and then run the additional
that's the time doesn't doesn't approval
get to see what they never you begin no
the prover you're still seeing I'm gonna
run some tests here right and you have
to specify your tables and then once he
specified these tables likely to pick my
bathtub so essentially what it's doing
for the reason since there are several
copies for each day no no no no the
Delta is just the only Delta controls it
sort of that the the the probability
distribution would Victor which I picked
x y&z right what we assume that the room
don't be as unit approver actually knows
that hold all the reservation yeah in
all of the distribution but I mean I'm
still using the same or very old r it
improves right I'm just asking the
prover you know we have the label cover
here I want the long codes for these
guys and now i'm going to pick an Xyz
here and the distribution with which I
picked XYZ depends on Delta just a mixed
you so once the proven has specified a
certain proof I'll pick my own Delta and
run this region yes so when you convert
this to a three CNF it just multiplies
to size the number of pulses like hey is
it correct and no it did sort of
something I swept under the rug is that
I sort of have a look yeah I have you
know probability distributions right so
I actually waited instance of Mexicans
37 thank you you peek so for each other
have a the probability of picking XYZ
will go over to wait and this weight
will change now when i read weight would
not change my delta right that's just
sort of goes into the weight thing in
the three sentences
does the I even before everything life
before paying the edge yes yeah that's
perfectly fine this you can see it i
have k different tests with different
deltas and I first decide which of these
tests i'm going to do or you can sort of
think of it inside the distribution it
works equally fine everybody happy with
this no sorry I didn't get why does this
work again well and ice so what does it
say well I had this I have this um I
need to estimate right okay so it
contains beta so we know that the sum of
the J had paid us some 21 dan and I
can't sometimes fruit I can't control
this multiplier except for this
troublesome part okay but the point is
once I pick a random king I sort of get
a random of K disjoint intervals this
means that the sub some of these guys in
the problem at the gentle would be will
be at most 1 over K 0 on average so
there I can't control this multiplying
factor but I ok yeah that's a good
question George chocolate or error and
ready for sure what okay so it's every
sign like this solution and I used it
again when I did max not to later but
i'll show you the solution that has its
we're taught only twice but actually i
worked like you know 20 times which is
much more useful so you're happy with
this solution sort of
come
first like how well you can approach you
are worried about the seven over 8 plus
the little function there's like square
root of the others that then you have to
worry about these intervals yeah yeah
yeah sure yeah well it and yes I can
really yes you're saying you know what I
want an approximation ratio that seven
nights plus epsilon and then it's the
question you know how this this epsilon
affecting us dance and it's clearly I'll
need here an epsilon that's greater than
1 over K yeah okay because that's the
way I can control things which means
that it and i also want alone to need
epsilon greater than Delta zero and that
sort of says that the first test is
pretty small and then these actually
decreased quite a lot so I'll have what
much worse constants in this that's
definitely true yeah sorry I thought
they understood but no one confused
again so the proper he gets to see what
your choice of those days no not the
prettiest he just writes down the proof
once a fraud but you asked him to
evaluate G into points no no I evaluate
yield it's right he writes down the
table once and for all right and I god I
flipped my index and go there and read
this position right it's a written proof
it's not an interactive proof anymore
but he's written down the proof and I
flip my bits and I go and read three
positions and that's it okay
so we
so the obvious thing which didn't occur
to me but occurred to serve as good
number of years later is that what we
can change the label cover instance and
in fact with high probability put that
in fact if you were a recently small set
and they're here you should set this
thing called say beta smaller than a
delta to the minus 2 or something we
actually want the projection to be
one-to-one with high probability over
the choice of a random net so how do we
do this well what what did we have
before
if i remember correctly
okay so before we if you remember we had
sort of tea closest that we sent to p 1
and T variables that we sent work i'll
call this k in the good old days right
this is how our original label cover was
constructed
so the simple thing I will do is just
take general capital T closes which will
be a number much greater than k and i'll
send them to both groups and alaska
don't only want this k variable as I
also want this sort of this checking
questions i also want these three t
variables that appears in these clothes
and to the other prove i won't tell them
which are the ones i'm going to check in
which our own only for you know
different from each other and variables
which has an entire close to the other
proof
Oh
Oh
Oh
Oh
so now I claim that the probability that
two things project to the same thing is
bounded by something like k / t which
can fear these numbers and times the
size of a time I just proved this at the
same and take any two things that belong
to beta now I have to think what are
these labels with these labels our
assignment today to the T plus K closes
some to p1 so and they differ in at
least one of these clauses and with
extremely high probability you know we
let chose that variable that's in that
close to send was it to p2 and which
means that the projections are different
and since there are like Peyton size of
beta squared things and the probability
that we fail is like a over two years
this is redundant
the better square comes from Union bound
of all pairs of yeah yeah I mean T is if
we don't really care about the console
entities we could do better maybe put
yeah okay and here I'm really asked if
I'd of having the same size projection
didn't need to insist on the same size
projection but this is sort of just
being so everybody so we want to modify
the outside label cover to have this
smooth this is called smooth they played
the cold smooth by super chocolate
orange juice well there will random
process right we choose t plus K
different random closest and we of which
you know almost all goes to both probers
and K of them with pics 1 learning from
the same the same collection with the
original cake yeah these are
indistinguishable I mean it's important
to these are indistinguishable to p1
right it doesn't know which because
that's what that's used to write
well well we're moving head to unique
games but then this is a one to one
really one to one mapping but yeah on
soon on small sets it's a one-to-one
mapping it sort of makes and still
randomly because otherwise I it's very
easy to construct a small set where the
projection is much smaller yeah so yes
this is me too we have to fix one guy
over here and then take the expectations
over the choice on a random neighbor and
then we can control these services to
put so you're happy with that we
actually can control this term so sure I
should show you how these things
actually make us control these terms
it's just sort of a gap I mean the only
a fatal less than Delta to the minus two
pair but even for large a bit I can't be
much larger than and so that is what we
have to UM so let's see if I didn't
but this sort of sense that if beta is
so let's take T to be a delta to the
minus 5
rifle I mean we we impacted incredibly
strong bonds right i mean that is we all
have unique projections they're all one
and we sort of get an absolute value
thats you know really incredibly good
and if beta is greater than this then
you know the size of our beta is greater
than not the thing itself but by Delta
2-2 you don't take any any Delta to the
minus two elements here they probably
project on two different things so the
projection is big so then you have 1
minus Delta to the Delta 2 minus 2 which
is
good so now we just have to do this is
the easy term right now we have to do
the hard Kirk
so hot three doesn't leave it after the
prayer repetition or the repetition um
yeah so the question is so let's do that
after repair the repetition okay so you
add T random closest to both sides so
sound you know you can worry about
complete completeness is never a
problems you can work possibly about
soundness but for any fixed way of
adding capital T closes you have a copy
of the old game so soundness can't go up
right well won't go up at least maybe it
will go down I don't know what by the
reputation idea to be easily if you have
a copy of the game plan every fixed k
minus 1 but if the Sun is could go down
my suppose contd if adding this i'm
looking at run but you were talking a
little easier I'll through an happen
because look I'm just saying that you
could try to give the same argument for
value reputation because you have a copy
of the game Alyssa you just think this
is something to prove they say Leslie
gets it let's say let's ignore this part
I think so let's see it's easier to just
think of changing the big the original
to approval game so that you ask you
know the first player for clothes just
like before and instead of asking the
second player for a valuable you ask the
circuit player for a close with one
minus something Oh mobility and only
with a small talk with you ask the
second player about a valuable inside
the clothes and then when you found the
power to power petition oh well that
you get this picture okay yeah that's
another way to view good so
so now we have your you know are our
three set test with Delta we will later
choose Delta with this you know random
you know Delta 1 0 to delta k with equal
probabilities but let's just call it
Delta and we just do this
I've me
so as we had before I mean it turns with
different betas for the expansion show
of y and z will disappearing I'm not I
won't worry about these things and then
we'll have
so I do I take it for it expansion
everywhere I the Terms where we have
different characters for y and z will
disappear and then only I'll get what we
have you and
so can you end it can we first get rid
of any more terms you know fun
or what did you say or how can we get
rid of all beat that because you had
their phone yes but well even beat us
does interfere with what because they're
interested here right
alright
like if I also saw the subset of the
projection and in fact you know maybe
take any X I that XJ that lives in our
fun but not in Phi Beta and then you'll
have something in that product that's in
fact independent of everything else and
we'll be fine okay so we can factor
alpha substituted
so the expected value not turns out to
be
Oh
so now if you just well you have to look
at it you know you split the terms oh
[ __ ] call me see Jace where legs chase
RS before the contribution singular some
older beta such levels this is a term
yet but we're sending over alphas and
betas were off as a subset of beta and
we have this term and then we evaluate
this expectation is characteristic move
this summer of yeah yeah yeah so this is
hey listen what fun yes good so now we
just have to estimate this thing and he
question is how much fun we're going to
have a big most of this month old but
most of this fun before now we have a
lot more fun now right because now we
have a sum over the the alphas also okay
so if you have one of these things is
always nice to ma'am cuz you try to sort
of fun right
and so let's see if I can
how
well let's let's let's let's first start
with the big terms
so someone's always worried about big
beta today we
both
Oh
so let's look at the big British what we
have to purchase works on this one and
then we have to look at this number and
we want this I claim that in fact this
number is smaller than 1 and this number
is more than one so you're fixing me
just fix it may I see what the
multiplier is and the multiply is this
number and I well we can have absolute
values everywhere if we these are
positives this might have signs but okay
and yeah I never did this on the board
you know and it's not and I just have to
check that this sum okay
so let's get a little bit more feeling
for what why this song is actually small
well if you call this number AJ in this
number PJ we can in fact see that they
have to cancelling guys over here so if
SJ is positive both these two numbers
are in fact positive and sum to 1 and if
s Jace is old than both these numbers
are negative in the Sam 2-1
this is because / or for easy well it's
this set of things in the projection of
vector but not in alpha I don't know
possibly well yeah but you know what
else could it be so then I came what in
fact it's up to once if you look at the
squares since neither of these numbers
exactly one you know there are two
numbers less than one that sum to one
that we square them and when we square
them to get something that's less than
one and this fact this number is in fact
if you look at it it's exactly this son
this is exactly the product of the sums
of the scripts if you just expand
everything
it's exactly yeah right
well
we're summing over all alphas the
product of G alpha subsets of some set
here hi bata 8
whatever direction is should go
if your if you sum over all subsets and
on this this is if I think this is just
a true identity right right if you
expand this out you get exactly this
thing and that's exactly the thing we
have over there and now we found these
terms so this means that we actually now
have some term it goes exponentially
smooth so and the size of the projection
we can control because it paid this big
than the projection is big so these
terms go to 0 these are these are smooth
so
so what I claim it i did so far is that
if you look at the big sets and in fact
they contribute very good yes because I
do get a bound only in the size of the
projection and in fact i'm using it here
on on the size of listen
which means that this sum is large and
then you say well this sum is in fact
smaller than alpha subject type of beta
make this more of the latter half and
I'm also something on bed of course
so now using cool t-shirt with you're
taking one F in 1g to one side and then
taking the other g and the P to the
other side but this sum is again small
which sort of me is that if you know
this term is freak that in fact this
term is big and that gives us as
strategy in the label cover because we
are only have small sets here so we know
the sets are small in then we're done
and that's the entire proof
why is the second factor small right so
we just the fixed beta sum over up first
then in fact we had just a moment ago
that the sum of that if you fix Payton
some already alphas then that's a small
sum and then when we sum so this means
that we can get rid of this and this and
then we have some debate over other
three coefficients of G and that's the
most one right this this summer alphas
of this gives something smooth and then
the right okay the patina that actually
came can't you just can you know oh now
the piece no I don't I don't care that
it's smooth would have been sufficient
that it was almost one okay yeah but I'm
have to make sure it doesn't blow up on
me all right so one without being a good
enough estimate there because that would
I make this big well sorry that so I'm
right if you're selling this we can move
this sum and then we get you know 1
minus Delta to the pi beta and then we
actually just get that this is smaller
than 1 because you know better my vs
water and then the other boys you don't
get a vote on the one by beta because
beta is small here yeah once we make
this now into strategies we'd have the
same similar term but we want to repeat
that but since we only have small sets
beta that's fine before we had that
alpha was equal to the pie too but in
fact that as a subset with it was
equally good for us and ever you know
these are three coefficients all of our
original functions of the non endian
support them and we're done so now I had
a couple homework problems for you guys
because these proofs are not so
enjoyable right so the first thing is
that
which is normally the homework last time
please tell you what this so do it for
four settings that okay that it's hard
to approximate for set within 15 / 16
then in fact you can set up your own you
need you know F X and then my Z and the
w well not a different type of wo on the
other side but you have much more
freedom if we go from three set of force
that things get a lot easier so there
you can do it and you can sort of do the
free analytic thing you don't have to
use this all this mess that I use with
the different pages on the projection of
the pages okay this is a nice homework
exercise which is simpler than what I
the other homework problem that very
nice homework problem is to say let's
did three linn which was sort of easy
right let's do four lynden step okay
which is in fact easier but let's insist
on having all right hand sides equal to
minus one we want to pull harness for
the case when all right hand sides or
minus one so let's you if you can't tell
me the rough how should you set things
up here's pretty clear how you should
set things up right here on the next y
and z and let's i don't want a na'vi say
such that x pi I why I of Zi Zi never
equals 1 of 10 11 and then you want some
probability distribution on these
strings and then you do the Fourier
transform and then you you work for
what's the difference in how do you even
make sure that you get the right hand
side minus 1 nourriture exactly you
cannot fold okay
alright
so this means you can't assume that your
tables are unbiased and in particularly
get in trouble with the Fourier
coefficients for the empty set because
now suddenly sets can become empty and
how do you get around up that are the
two homework exercises so you can still
fold one side now you can't fall I mean
how would you want at folding sort of
makes and enters negations in your
instance right it's clear here you want
to the condition I mean for this is what
I want x pi i potentially I'm not saying
that well I like this exercise so much
else saw it on the board for you okay so
you would sort of Montes also choose
these things potentially you know three
guys one guy to the left and three to
the right to make sure that and ask
these to be minus one but you're not
going to have folding here okay so this
means you have to ask for f of X to your
wine G of Z tier VIII this is what
you're going to test right this cannot
work n minus 1 yeah yeah yeah this
cannot work because you can make a wall
the F variables equal to minus 1 and all
the G sequel to one or the other way
around and that would repeal you do you
do you can do for Union and the final
instance u- enables no you shouldn't of
folding right i mean because if you if
you folding and I mean you can sort of
look at the fault you can see what that
should look like but that's not a good
way to do it so I'm as a one thing we
proved before right is that I had
uselessness what solutions are equally
good right in the soundless case we only
always get the Union from this
usually this situation is in fact
different because we have unusually bad
solutions I mean the solution that gives
all the variables value one in fact will
have no correct equations so we won't
have uselessness in the sense that we
get a uniform distribution here but and
we actually have to do some I mean we
have to make sure that some sign comes
the term actually has to write sorry but
that's all about the exercises and now
if you want to go to a theory lunch i
think i might as well stop your woods
does anybody want to go to theory lunch
okay well and then we can talk to you if
I have some things to say and unless he
had planned to be done by now so I was
speeding a little bit but that's any
okay yeah any particular reason from the
smaller side well you we're not solving
exercises that I want questions you can
solve the exercise and then you can get
the chopped up next time so let's go the
other way if i'm going to talk on my own
let's go to the other direction ok let's
do two side
so the next problems I want to talk
about this two sides were too little
this is sort of well to lean is really
linear equations with two unknowns but
there are only two two ways to have
linear equations with two unknowns and
that sort of equalities and inequalities
so now you really have trouble if you
want to label cover go from label cover
and you want to pick now you're going to
read two bits right and then my lid
you're not going to read two bits here
or two bits there right you have to read
one bit on each sides probably but then
how can you possibly say something yeah
re kid with some probability route to
bits on the right side just to ensure
something yeah I'd like that its other
end yeah true so you can think about it
and will return to this but the most
popular way to do this is to google jets
right so
so in fact we forget the PCP technology
for a while and we don't gadget it's not
so since the new level going is just to
query skype clear to put it on surprise
now we got the Leprechaun question is
just one will you be here one variable
here and check something yes right so so
doing this it's not clear doing a
similar thing doesn't necessarily well
so what I've sort of been saying that
you know I only know how to analyze
these by free analysis and to really
make sense of free analysis i want sort
of random each individual question to be
random because you know the fourier
coefficients or expectations yes or yes
ran i want to note that shouldn't be
independent but each question should be
uniformly distributed in the table that
I'm that's what I'm a bike by random yes
I couldn't for example force the food
right down a long hold of every inch and
then either in it you know test the edge
or test at the edges consistent with the
left side of me adjusting system of the
right yes yes for you if i get time that
that's what you'll have to do but that's
not catching I change it would be yeah
you can let's have another homework
problem to think how you do this in so
the data I want to take now is I want to
do gadget I want to tell you how to do
optimal gadgets and then maybe unravel
and see what the gadget means here okay
maybe but you can sort of so but maybe
how does anybody know who gentes you're
happy with gadgets these kind of gadgets
let me write down again it may be it for
my planning for tomorrow
Oh
so this is a three-set 22 circuit and it
has the property if this clause is
satisfied if this is satisfied there
exists a value for a such that seven
closes are true definitely for it yeah
this is a name well if flow is not
satisfying best day gives six close
now I forgot this is an old gadget that
existed already in the 70s so this short
show that max 2sat was MP harder to
approximate it max 2sat was hard what's
hard in the worst case because three-set
was hoarding
so if you just take the three set thing
and sort of attach this gadget on top
and you get 5556 plus an arbitrary
epsilon producer so the thing i want to
discuss next is sort of saying you know
well this is what all magic you know
where does this gadget come from is
there probably better gadget how do you
find optimal guidance so the thing I
wanted that so they essentially what i
wanted to say next time is this results
that you know how to a way to construct
optimal gadgets i want to show you how
to do this how many people know this
result this is travis on sorkin sudan in
williamson that's high desert result i
really like so that's something I would
want to tell you about so the question
is you know how do you make an optimal
such thing in the definition is that you
just involve is third clothes yes so the
a for each claw Stabila has it in
individual a that just belongs to this
casual did use different age for the
different clauses on and that's it and
then it's question how can you get them
results for tool in and and to sat and
you know what what can you do there
that's what I want to do next why it is
called it gadgets and service reductions
I don't know they were called their
gadgets know it's a reduction yeah but
it's a very special type it's a very
special type of reduction right it's not
some big thing you just write down this
little thingy so bryce and pointed the
point is that you apply something very
local to each
to each test it's not a global reduction
you don't take lean out a combination of
any go over that what I don't know any
cool border with PCP is a global bit of
PCP through i'm going to take her a free
shot and then encode everything with a
big polynomial of it yeah I suppose
you're right in what the reductions we
known no before that time was by gadgets
and but it was only like Lenny harness
yeah it but it is a gadget no I don't
know the meaning of the word yet but
it's perfect perfectly after all and
[ __ ] she'll do this calculation I mean
that if they only useful thing I can do
in the last two miniature yeah I'll do
this when the losses 191 my 70th wonder
56 but we'll see if I if I remember it
right so we start with the three set
instance with L process then we get the
to set instance 10m closes
and we get the new em new variable so we
get one new variable for each close
right the a will have a elkin and
pointed out a new identity free each of
these guys won't buy 10 is not fine and
when one two three or five thousand oh
seven o'clock
and if you believe this property you
know if if f is this one if 5
satisfiable we can satisfy 7m new
inclusive and if we only can do three
queries sorry 7 8 plus Epsilon let me
get satisfied let me get 7 8 times 7 m +
18 minus epsilon x 6m this gives
55 / 56 sorry hey and in fact we even
get plus epsilon night so that gives the
protein villa theresa so it's really the
ratio between the quality of the
important to promise to remember here is
that you know you get the 78 is one
thing that enters this calculation and
the other thing is this to number seven
and six that enters the calculation did
final thing is just an easier you know
average of these two function on these
two things is it 55 / 8 then you like by
its own entity oh yeah sorry yeah sorry
yeah yeah I can still do it buddy yeah
yeah thanks well you want an apple sorry
you won't stop it good but that's it for
today them so is it conceivable that
there's a gadget reduction from just
gives you 7 8 37 from where I'm just
bias you know this reason no but if you
need an approximate e results to start
with right i mean if you don't have any
proxima built yourself from the gadget
from you so i mean the thing i got i got
the first way I got 3sat wasn't and
reduction from three linn right and that
more sort of a gadget I mean the most
primitive gadget reduction without any
auxiliary variable signal I just sort of
said that this condition is actually but
it gets much more interesting when you
have a silver variables yes so you said
something with optimal gadget so it's
this
get an optimal like it's a value six or
seven optimal forget introduction
problem is that 22 that I think so but I
have to check this but it would be a
homework problem how many homework till
you have now no but that's not a
homework problem until I had the next
lecture but the homework problems today
you still remember them you will wrote
them down carefully right for sat and
fall in with right hand side minus one
ok